bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
dans le kiosque votre magazine culturel
regardons tout de suite le sommaire de
notre émission
profiter de la base de loisirs de saint
quentin pour fêter halloween au
programme ce jeudi 31 octobre
fabrication de lanternes citrouille
préparation de souffle et pour
frissonner parcourez les arbres de nuit
nos invités nous donne tous les détails
dans quelques instants l'estaminet à
manille les amoureux vais lui aussi pour
quelques jours les couleurs d'halloween
parents et enfants confectionnent les
déguisements ont vu du défilé de jeudi
les 6 et 9 novembre la ferme de bel ébat
vous invite au voyage à travers une
fable japonaise femme oiseau nicolas
gervais a rencontré à la main si le
metteur en scène de ce spectacle
poétique chaque semaine septième art est
mise à l'honneur dans notre chronique
cinéphiles mari d'une poule du cinéma
les yeux d'elsa saint cyr l'école nous
livrera son coup de coeur
halloween c'est déjà demain et pour ceux
qui souhaitent préparer cette fête comme
il se doit ou encore ils participer de
façon originale la base de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines propose de
nombreuses activités nous en parlerons
ce soir avec nos invités françois bisson
soir alors vous êtes responsable du
parcours branché loisirs et fabienne du
croquant soir reçoivent d'être
responsable de la ferme pédagogique
voilà je m'adresse à vous en premier
parc à la ferme vous allez organiser une
activité
confection de lanternes citrouilles en
en a eu d'ailleurs sur le plateau que
vous nous avez apporté alors comment on
commence à cette animation voilà donc la
ferme pédagogique propose des ateliers
tout au long de l'année est donc là pour
le cadre d' halloween on organise donc
la confection de lanternes de
citrouilles et on va pas se faire
uniquement la lanterne on va utiliser
aussi l'intérieur de la citrouille donc
pour confectionner une soupe et ensuite
on leur apprend aussi des choses sur les
citrouilles différentes activités que
vous commencez en fait par une petite un
retour l'histoire sur le légume en lui
même voilà on leur présente donc la
citrouille en tant que tel on a aussi
des potirons on a aussi des potimarrons
donc on leur explique la différence
ensuite les enfants choisissent leur
citrouille donc les fratries près d'une
grosse citrouille qui creusent ensemble
et qu'ils utilisent pour la maison
ensemble les enfants qui viennent tout
seuls ont une plus petite et donc ils la
choisissent et ensuite on leur explique
les différentes étapes qui va falloir la
creuse et récupérer les graines pour
éventuellement planté l'année prochaine
dans leur jardin s'il le souhaite et il
la creuse avec l'aide des parents au
début parce qu'il ya des certaines
parties à faire au couteau et donc ce
n'est pas trop dangereux alors voilà on
demande que les parents soient sur place
il ya aussi des animateurs de la ferme
pédagogique donc qu'ils sont là pour
accompagner donc on fournit des couteaux
donc plus ou moins tranchant suivant
l'âge des enfants et on demande vraiment
aux parents de participer à cette étape
donc de couper c'est l'enfant qui
dessinent au feutre
ce qui veut découper sur la citrouille
et les parents aident les enfants donc
on assiste vraiment sur ce point là et
il ya les animateurs en plus pour aider
s'il ya besoin qu'il faut un type de
citron particulier à l'arrière ce set
décor est alors il ya des citrouilles
qui s'appelle les jack o lantern ou qui
sont vraiment les citrouilles
d'halloween qui sont toutes rondes et
orange donc c'est des citrouilles qui
ont l'avantagé d'être facile à creuser
mais par contre c'est des citrouilles
qui est au niveau gustatif ont peu
d'intérêt donc vu que c'est vrai que
nous on fait de la soupe derrière on a
choisi donc soit des potirons comme
celle qui est devant et des potimarrons
donc on a un goût très intéressant et
par contre qu'ils sont durs à creuser
donc on à l'effroi qui sont sur place
donc les enfants choisissent et y
découvre qu'elle est plus ou moins dures
à creuser mais après tout est transformé
en lanterneaux la pelouse et des
citrouilles issus de votre propre
potager voilà donc on a une partie des
citrouilles qui sont produites sur place
donc on
mais un peu victime du succès donc du
coup on a dû en acheter à l'extérieur
aussi parmi eux voilà bien sûr mais
c'est bien alors giflé mois là certaines
sont issus de la ferme pédagogique ans
victime du succès parce que notamment
cet après midi donc avait lieu un
atelier qui sera également
reconduit donc demain dès 14 heures à la
ferme pédagogique de la base de loisirs
et nous avons rencontré justement cet
après midi les enfants qui ont participé
à l'atelier et nous expliquent ils ont
expliqué anthony rachat elodie moines à
quoi ressemble leur citrouille on les
écoute moi j'ai décidé à venir ce géant
j'ai la graine il est ici je fais un
chapeau à ma citrouille
j'ai gratté intérieures jai enlever les
graines maintenant je vais faire les
yeux la bouche pour le chapeau on a fait
une étoile pour un peu décorer la
citrouille
pour les yeux on a fait des coeurs pour
le nez on a c'est un carré
pour la bouche bah comme matisse al
mutanabbi gentille vent de la ceni mais
voilà alors voilà on peut personnaliser
ses face à ces trous si on veut des
coeurs pour les yeux c'est possible
voilà on laisse les enfants choisir en
fait ils font preuve de créativité ceux
qui choisissent dont on leur a montré on
leur a fait un modèle juste pour qu'ils
comprennent ce qu'ils vont faire parce
que pour les enfants les plus petits ce
n'est pas forcément évident et au feutre
ils font ce qu'ils veulent en fait sur
la citrouille qui choisissent et alors
comme vous et comme rien ne va se perdre
on va pouvoir être utilisés l'intérieur
vous allez également utilisés en courant
pour faire une soupe un velouté de
citrouille telle est la recette alors le
velouté de citrouille c'est très très
simple au final donc l'idéal ce soit des
potirons soit des potimarrons on
récupère la chair qui à l'intérieur donc
on enlève la partie filandreuse et les
graines on garde pour les replanter
l'année prochaine on coupante idée on
met tout dans un grand faitout voix
l'employeur on met un terme aux éleveurs
donc pour faire revenir une fois que ça
commence à être assez mou ou en rajoute
de l'eau juste à prouver en fait non on
remet en remuant revu une fois que c'est
bien nous on passe au mixeur et après on
peut faire soit une version sucrée soit
une version salée en réactivant goût
donc le sucré passe bien avec les
enfants
rajouter du fromage fondu bien connu on
va dire et après donc soit on rajoute du
sucre version sucrée pour les enfants ou
sel poivre plus classique en version sa
petite touche de crème aussi on peut
aussi moins d'accord au rsa c'est
parfait et puis vous pourrez donc
pendant que ça a lieu sur plein du coup
là la ferme voilà vous avez une cuisine
aménagée pour alors donc on organise
tout vu le beau temps l'unesco à
l'extérieur donc on a des plaques un
faitout et pendant la cuisson donc de la
soupe on propose aux enfants de
découvrir la ferme pédagogique et donc
de faire le tour des enclos avec les
animateurs donc pour caresser les poules
hélas pour les moutons les chèvres une
après midi bien ou mal à me plaire
s'allonger à la ferme fait d'accord
alors on va se tourner maintenant du
côté du parcours est donc cette
découverte des arbres alors de nuit
parce que finalement la spécificité à la
base de loisirs pour la crown heights et
que ça va avoir lieu donc d'equivallée
de la nuit tombée en fait je voulais
déjà françois nous rappeler juste le
principe de la croma le principe de la
crown heights est de réaliser de
l'accrobranche mais du coup un comme
vous visiez cinéma de nuit vous allez
avoir des lampes frontales sur la sur la
tête ce qui vous permette du coup
d'éclairer ce que vous allez voir et à
partir de là vous évoluez donc sur les
parcs les mêmes parcours les parcours
d'accrobranche alors ses emails parcours
que des jours c'est exactement le même
parcours que deux joueurs du cool
adaptation et que vous le faites de nuit
donc du coup avec une vision et un chant
qui est complètement différent savoure
une toute autre perspective
il faut être parti s'aguerrir non c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment abordable pour
tous
alors sur les contrairement à la journée
on accueille à partir de à partir de 6
ans pour la nuit et du coup après c'est
je tirais de 6 à 77 ans on espère on pas
du coup un passant de 77 ans quand même
un minimum de forme physique mais c'est
quand même vraiment un portable à tous
quand on a quatre parcours différents
voilà ces quatre parcours en fonction de
son niveau est à pratiquer exactement
voilà on a quatre parcours oncle vers le
bleu le rouge et le noir qui sont dans
l'ordre croissant et en fonction de
battre son niveau et son
de son ressenti sur les différents
parcours on peut évoluer dit à petit
pour terminer sur le noir qui est
beaucoup plus difficile qu'elle quels
éléments de sécurité vous mettez alors
veillez à un baudrier 1 et un baudrier
qui s'appelle aussi un harnais ch sur
lequel on vient d'acheter du matériel et
vous avez un crochet de ligne de vie
continue qui permet du coup d'avoir un
an peut-être accrochant permanent si
vous avez un mousqueton qui lui permet
de se déplacer et d'éventuellement de
s'accrocher sur différentes choses
d'accord et puis le parcours est balisé
le parcours bah du coup être le digne de
crochets ligne de vie continue vous
n'avez qu'un seul chemin possible un
petit peu comme le jeu dans la célèbre
fort boyard vous êtes avec le crochet
vous avancer il faut trouver le bon
chemin là c'est un petit peu pareil sauf
que du coup c'est beaucoup plus évident
est beaucoup plus clair alors c'était la
nuit vous avez un câble en fait sur
lequel vous êtes un du coup accroché à
un mur le crochet de vous déplacer votre
chauffe est en mesure sur ce câble
installé d'atelier en atelier d'arbre en
arbre sans jamais faire demi tour c'est
quand même ça paraît compliqué comme my
cité mais c'est plutôt très simple une
fois bouzid alors c'est une
animation en fait que vous avez déjà mis
en place a depuis avril vous devez un
retour d'expérience effectivement oui si
bonnet alors qu'elle est illustré pas
c'est une élection c'est effectivement
une activité qui a lancé lancé depuis
début avril donc un soul sous le
principe de la crosse d'un le nom de la
crown heights
mais se situe qu'à la base de loisirs
cette attaque est spécifique parce que
spécifique à base de loisirs dont une
activité pas qu'on fait comme je vous
expliquais de nuit un chacun à chaque et
je dirais édition environ à peu près
tous les lieux tous les mois pendant les
périodes d'ouverture dont on essaye de
trouver des petites choses pour venir
pimenter un peu plus atteints il ya ceux
pour halloween alors qu'est ce que vous
mettez en place d' un peu spécifique
donc la bad spécifique forcément déjà un
petit peu de déco un petit peu de déco
on invite fortement les personnes qui
nous rejoignent pour venir pratiquer un
de venir déguisé on essaiera par nous
par la même occasion du coude et yves
également et puis on propose un
maquillage fluo donc du coup que cette
fois cette fois ci sera beaucoup plus
orienté forcément vers des thématiques
halloween halloween d'accord alors
qu'elle est fou qu'on précise parce que
le 31 octobre en fait c'est la dernière
date de la saison puisque ensuite ça
s'arrête et ça reprendra l'année
prochaine alors effectivement pour la
crown heights la dernière de la saison
sinon on est ouvert jusqu'au 10 ou 15
novembre pour la croma est effectivement
c'est la dernière c'est la dernière de
l'année vous les arrangements profiter
voilà c'est maintenant ou jamais sinon
ça sera l'année prochaine alors on n'a
pas précisé mais que ce soit pour la
ferme pédagogique ou pour la chronique
il faut réserver c'est ça voilà réservé
au niveau de la ferme pédagogique pour
qu'on ait le nombre de citrouilles en
conséquence et après si malheureusement
pour cette édition c'est pas possible
pour noël on fera des ateliers à
d'autres vacances offrent d'autres
ateliers pour rappel juste le coup c'est
qu'ils n'auront pas 6 euros enfant voilà
et puis pour le la crown heights et en
une fourchette parce que ses fonctions
des sanctions du parcours que vous allez
vendre et
szavay 2-6 en main ça risque réduit en
groupe et c'est globalement c'est entre
18 et 28 euros 50 voilà donc rendez vous
sur le site internet ou sur en
téléphonant aux numéros qui sont
affichées pour réserver merci beaucoup
d'être venus et deux sur la place du
kiosque alors nous continuons et cette
fois ci nous partons du côté de
l'estaminet à magny les hameaux parce
que les samyn a lieu également
revêtissent et ses couleurs d'halloween
parents et enfants ont confectionné des
déguisements pour le défilé de jeudi
image de patrick jacq des 10 km
cette semaine à l'estaminet un magny les
hameaux les enfants on se prépare à
fêter halloween on peut faire plein de
choses on décore on prépare et on va
prendre des bonbons avant le défilé du
jeudi 31 octobre il collecte de maumont
une fois se mettre au travail création
des décors confection de déguisements il
ne reste que quelques jours pour être
fin prêt on fait des costumes pour l'un
d'eux une police enfants pour qu'ils se
marre bien le jour
d'autres défilés et on y fait de la
couture ou en effet
des petits trucs c'est sympa on a fait
avec une autre idée on fait comme la
tête il dit d
comment dire
on invente aussi j'adore les enfants
j'aime bien être avec eux et puis je
donne un peu de temps vu que leurs
vacances au
copains ou copines
donner un peu de son temps et partager
des moments en famille c'est aussi
l'objectif de cet atelier on essaye de
travailler avec les parents et les
enfants en même temps un père amener des
familles qui sont un pays seul élément
poussant à la mesure qui travaillent pas
et pendant c'est toujours les vacances
scolaires elle aime pas beaucoup
d'occupations parce que l ont pas les
moyens pour payer les frais des loisirs
et l'objectif c'est de ramener ces
famines et ces femmes là l'erreur et
faire de rencontres entre les mamans et
les enfants
jeanne et merci parce qu'elle est tout
seul je l'expliquais j'ai dit tu vas
avoir des enfants
voilà qui va devoir faire beaucoup de
choses qu'elle était très contente
au même temps moi aussi j'aimerais bien
voir des mamans parler partager quoi
qu'est ce qu'ils font là et c'est bien
ce qu'ils font les enfants défileront
déguisés jeudi à 18 heures dans le
quartier du buisson
et vous allez-vous fêter halloween c'est
la question que nous vous avons posé
dans les rues de 51 en janvier on fêtera
pas halloween pour ce qu une fête
commerciale les bonbons en mange toute
l'année ma fille met un peu la pression
pour que hans équipe en conséquence des
tenues de sorcière 1 pour des enfants de
cet âge là si longue
c'est ce qui se dit couture et oui
éventuellement si pas ce genre donne
toujours quelque chose va un petit peu
d'orange est en fait quelques petites
citrouilles et un haïti décoration des
bougies voilà histoire de parfaire la
tradition et puis on accroche quelque
chose de en lan espèce de gros trucs aux
oranges pour prévenir les enfants qui
peuvent taper à la porte ici quoi non
non les enfants sont grands maintenant
ça on le sait depuis et on a toujours
une petite réserve à la maison s'il ya
des enfants qui passent sur les enfants
de la résidence qui participe donc en
général on fait ce qu'il faut pour un
stock conséquent de bonbons pour
satisfaire tout le monde ah non pas du
tout parce que c'est pas nos traditions
n'ont pas décoration de maison par
contre s'ils vont chercher des bonbons
il se déguise oui
retrouvons sans plus attendre nicolas
gervais dans sa chronique pour le casque
cette semaine nicolas nous fait
découvrir la femme oiseau une fable
japonaise présenté les 6 et 9 novembre
la ferme de bel ébat rencontre avec
alain bâtis le metteur en scène de ce
spectacle poétique
la femme oiseau ou à la bâtisse
s'inspire de cette légende japonaise
pour donner naissance à un spectacle
ponctué de chansons qui sera présenté
notamment les 6 et 9 novembre à la ferme
de bel ébat à guyancourt un spectacle
zen pour toute la famille hess avait dû
petit scarabée quant aux japonais que ce
que signifie mon émission préférée non
si ça c'est dit coeur
seulement
la femme oiseau c'est effectivement une
vieille légende
japonaise que peut-être aurait pris sa
source en chine où 7e siècle et qui open
qui aurait comme ça vous voyagez
jusqu'au japon est en fait en 2000 j'ai
mis en scène un roman de maxence fermine
qui s'appelle neige et qui était comme
ça à l'épopée d'un jeune homme épris de
la neige et de l'art du haïku est à ce
moment là je me suis mis à lire plein de
contes et de légendes
japonaise voilà je suis tombé sur cette
heure sur cette légende là et elle
m'avait vraiment marqué j'ai eu comme ça
le désir d'écrire à partir de cette
légende là une pièce de théâtre en vingt
tableaux
c'est l'histoire d'un jeune homme est
loué qui amateurs de neige découvre sera
un chemin lorsqu'il va dans la forêt une
grue blessé à l'oeil par des pêches et
développer cet oiseau soigner cet oiseau
son bord du chemin et le soir lorsqu'il
rentre chez lui tard dans la nuit on
vient frapper à sa porte et c'est une
jeune femme qui vit à lui demander
l'hospitalité et comme dans les contes
assez rapidement très vite la lui
demande s'il accepterait de la prendre
pour épouse il ya le bonheur qui
s'installe on danse dans ce foyer là et
puis un moment donné bon voilà ils sont
pauvres et la femme se propose de tisser
pour lui une étoffe qui va soulever la
curiosité du village puisqu'avec cette
étoffe en récolte beaucoup d'argent
c'est une pièce qui raconte finalement
l'extrême générosité qui
voilà qui fait partie de cette femme qui
espèce de créature comme ça voilà elle
s'est transformée
finalement cessé de rue qui s'est
transformée en femme oiseau et qui va
jusqu au sacrifice
par amour mais il y a un rapport à
l'argent parce qu'à un moment donné d'un
avec ces têtes ont gagné tellement
d'argent que tout le monde a envie de
connaître le secret finalement deux de
ceux de cet ethos
si vous voulez vous
on
rigolait moment
c'est la force des effectivement des
fables des légendes des mythes
finalement puisque elle raconte toujours
quelle que soit l'époque c'est à dire
évidemment aujourd'hui
cette idée du 2 la fascination
de pour la richesse raconte au va
vraiment beaucoup sur ce monde qui est
comme ça pas forcément extrêmement
égalitaire et donc c'est aussi une
invitation comme ça la réflexion à la
conscience pour les uns pour les autres
pour les petits et pour les grands on
toujours face à cette question là c'est
à dire de finalement désirer ce qui est
juste de vivre harmonieusement avec les
autres finalement
j'ai souhaité à partir de cette fable la
de décrire une pièce que j'ai appelé
poly sensorielle c'est à dire que j'ai
souhaité que sur le plateau se
rencontrent des univers différents la
musique
la marionnette
l'image puisqu'il y aura aussi de la
vidéo j'ai fait appeler à une et appelle
à une équipe qui était comme ça
des comédiens qui pouvait à la fois
effectivement manipuler chanter
jouer de la harpe du piano des flûtes
j'ai pensé comme ça avec alexandrine à
l'univers de oui un peu du japon quand
même finalement sans être voilà mais
assez petit assez kamishibaï sur des
petit théâtre japonais que qui sont
comme ça des petits théâtres que qui
sont qui sont véhiculés sur ces vélos où
finalement les gens viennent raconter
des histoires mais un kamishibaï
grandeur nature
c'est un spectacle
tout public
effectivement à partir de 7 ans pour moi
aussi la vertu d'être un spectacle
intergénérationnel
puisque finalement c'est une fable qui
va je crois provoquer de l'échangé la
discussion et puis un regard comme ça
entre l'adulte et l'enfant
et un sourire le mettre en terre
et voilà la femme oiseau c'est donc les
6 et 9 novembre à la ferme de bel ébat à
guyancourt et maintenant on retrouve non
pas une femme oiseau mais une femme qui
peut vous donner des ailes sans vous
clouer le bec ni vous voler dans les
plumes génome et aurélia à nicolas je
vous reconnais bien là gai comme un
pinson et jamais à bâiller aux
corneilles à la semaine prochaine
passons tout de suite à notre chronique
cinéphiles
nous sommes mercredi c'est donc l'heure
des sorties ciné au micro d' elodie
moines c'était bien dit rigolo
assez mervans et un peu bête il y avait
des activités plus drôle j'ai par
exemple quand il ya une fille s'appelle
jean qui a giflé quinquin
il y avait plus d'action aussi j'ai bien
aimé avait plus de monde c'est bien
vis de l'action il y avait de la
tristesse et c'était émouvant les lieux
de était mieux que le premier passé à
utiliser ce soit au niveau des effets
spéciaux
tout a été vraiment très bien la suite a
été mon avis c'était bien fort
lorsqu'il y avait du suspense il était
bien y avait des moments rigolos des
morts des moments fantastiques mais ça
fait un peu peur quand même moi qui ai
connu les années 70 il ya trop de
clichés 1 c'est le les voitures le métro
new yorkais tout ça mais la fin est
formidable entre les deux disent aux
écosystèmes français à l'américaine ça
va pas emballé la fin de compte
alors comme vous savez dans la chronique
siné si nous donnons aussi chaque
semaine la parole un professionnel du
cinéma qui nous livre son coup de coeur
cette semaine c'est au tour de marie
line pour responsables par hbo chargé
des relations avec le public pour le
cinéma les yeux d'elsa à
saint-cyr-l'ecole ans les quotas le coup
de coeur au cinéma lisez-le cette
semaine c'est la vie d'adèle chapitre 1
et 2 donc le film d'abdellatif kechiche
qui a eu la palme d'or à cannes c'est
l'histoire de deux femmes une histoire
d'amour on suit à dell de la formation
de
moore a un petit peu sa mise à l'épreuve
s'est centrée sur l'histoire d'amour
donc c'est une histoire d'amour absolu
entre deux femmes mais c'est aussi ça
parle aussi de la vocation d'une jeune
femme que sa vocation d'institutrice
c'est un peu aussi le sujet du film est
donc une histoire de couple
traditionnel à savoir pas forcément de
femmes et une histoire de couple et qui
vont être confrontés à cette question de
différences d'origine et du coup
différence d'aspiration on vient là
c'est un film vraiment d'une ampleur
assez considérable il fait 3 heures mais
on sent pas passer les trois heures sont
vraiment ces trois heures sont
nécessaires au projet du réalisateur sur
la forme ce qui est assez spécifique
dans sa façon de filmer on sait qu'il a
souvent deux caméras ce qui lui permet
vraiment de dessaisir beaucoup de choses
et il s'est souvent des gros plans
de ces assises pour être vraiment s'il
met le corps et les visages un peu comme
voilà comme des paysages on est au plus
près des émotions jusqu'où décorateur dû
prendre une conne je suis content pour
les gars
pourquoi tu pleures pas
comme les vacances ne sont pas terminées
je vous propose deux dates pour occuper
encore vos enfants la première l'atelier
design ton siège au musée de la ville
donc là vos enfants pourront se glisser
dans la peau de designers et fabriquer
leur propre siège c'est demain jeudi 31
octobre à 15 heures donc au musée de la
ville ateliers accessibles dès 6 ans
deuxième atelier ce sera samedi de
novembre toujours au musée de la ville
l'atelier chouette la ville rétrécit il
s'agit de recréer la ville nouvelle ses
rues ses places et ses carrefours
ateliers accessibles dès 5 ans voilà
notre édition est à présent terminée je
vous remercie de nous avoir suivi sur
téléfilm je vous retrouve la semaine
prochaine mercredi en direct à 18h 30
d'ici là profitez de tous les lieux
culturels de notre territoire ils sont
nombreux à mercredi